minutes before winning his Oscar Will
Smith went down an Oscar history for a
very different reason here's the story
behind the slap heard around the world
literally
Will Smith first became known for his
breakout role as a fictionalized version
of himself in the 1990s sitcom The Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air he also earned rave
reviews for his film debut in 1993's Six
Degrees of Separation and quickly
ascended to Bonafide movie star status
with massive hits like 1996's
Independence Day and 1997's Men In Black
Smith's charismatic performances in such
films require a certain kind of talent
but it's a talent that almost always
goes unrecognized by the academy after
1999's Wild Wild West was a critical and
box office disappointment Smith
transitioned to more serious acting with
his titular role in Michael Mann's 2001
biopic Ali playing the legendary boxer
earned Smith his first Oscar nomination
but he lost to Denzel Washington for
training day over the next two decades
the actor rapper producer's career would
volley back and forth between what he
hoped would be critical favorites and
more commercial fare don't
ever
do that again he received his second
Oscar nomination for his lead
performance as a struggling single
father in The Pursuit of Happiness this
time Forrest Whitaker won for the last
king of Scotland in 2015 Smith starred
in concussion as the doctor who
discovered chronic traumatic
encephalopathy and football players he
didn't make the 2016 best actor cut but
he and his wife Jada Pinkett Smith told
Good Morning America their boycott of
the event had only to do with the lack
of diversity in that Year's nominees
still Smith was widely perceived as
wanting to win one of those little gold
men one day
Will Smith's best chance for an Oscar
came with 2021's King Richard a film he
co-produced about the father of the
tennis playing Williams sisters King
Richard was almost universally liked by
critics and audiences in a relatively
weak year for movies only about 18
months removed from the start of the
covid-19 pandemic the film and its star
collected just about every Accolade that
they could leading up to the Oscars
awards are usually something of a horse
race with a campaign season not unlike
that of an election actors in particular
have to walk a fine line between being
available to press and Academy members
and being Overexposed Smith handled the
lead-up to the Academy Awards perfectly
he was Charming in interviews he used
his acceptance speeches to heat Praise
on his collaborators co-stars and the
Williams family he won every major
precursor to the Oscars including the
bafta SAG Golden Globe and multiple
critics prizes King Richard went on to
be nominated for six Academy Awards
including best actor and by March Smith
was the front-runner for the win winning
an Oscar is never a short thing even for
those at the top of the betting odds but
Smith was about as dominant as any best
actor candidate had ever been that night
at the Dolby Theater his victory was
practically a foregone conclusion
with only about an hour to go before his
dream of winning an Oscar seemed all but
guaranteed to come true Will Smith did
something that he'll surely regret for
the rest of his life Chris Rock took the
stage to present the award for best
documentary feature as his standard
procedure for Oscar presenters Rock had
some pre-written material to deliver
before listing the nominees Rock started
by teasing husband and wife Javier
Bardem and Penelope Cruz who were both
nominated for lead actor and actress
respectively then the stand-up comedian
went off script and turned his attention
to Will and Jada Pinkett Smith who sat
in the front row near the center the
offending punchline was Jada I love ya
GI Jane 2 can't wait to see it Smith
appeared to laugh at first as if being a
good sport about it and Jada rolled her
eyes a moment later Smith stood walked
on stage toward Rock and slapped him
across the face with his open right hand
Smith returned to a seat where he looked
decidedly more upset than he'd been only
a few seconds before and began shouting
at rock rock took a beat to compose
himself before saying that was a great
this night in the history of television
because award shows frequently feature
celebrity skits and stunts people in the
room as well as people watching on TV
couldn't tell whether the slap was a
clumsily executed attempt at comedy or a
real altercation between Will Smith and
Chris Rock however those seated nearby
Will and Jada seemed to realize what was
happening in real time Oscar Watchers at
home got their first clue that the slap
was real when the audio cut out during
the American broadcast ABC airs live
programs in the United States on a 22nd
delay had the tense exchange been a bit
the network wouldn't have taken this
step in the uncensored version Rock's
shock is apparent in the way he reacts
to the assault despite the deeply
uncomfortable tension in the Dolby
Theater Rock still had to award the
Oscar for best documentary to Questlove
for his film summer of soul in front of
a still confused crowd Quest love later
told Jimmy Fallon that he was meditating
during the announcement of his category
and wasn't aware of what had occurred
between his friends Smith and rock when
I opened my eyes I didn't realize like
why is everyone so quiet like I
literally was not present for that whole
entire moment while Will Smith's
Behavior was inexcusable Chris Rock's
joke was also criticized in the
immediate aftermath of the slap some
commenters merely pointed out that the
quip which was a reference to a nearly
25 year old movie wasn't very funny
however the majority of those discussing
the GI Jane line and the slap brought up
Jada Pinkett Smith's alopecia diagnosis
the actress went public with her
condition in a 2018 Instagram post she
explained that she chose to shave her
head when patches of her hair began to
fall out because she didn't want anyone
to think that she had undergone
something more serious such as brain
surgery Pinkett Smith said dealing with
and talking about the medical condition
was difficult but she remained in good
spirits the post was viewed more than
two million times and Pinkett Smith's
alopecia was fairly common knowledge by
2022 in the days after the ceremony
Rock's brother claimed to the Los
Angeles Times that the comedian wasn't
aware of Pinkett Smith's diagnosis and
wouldn't have gone there had he no known
about her struggles with hair loss
Hollywood's a small world according to
Newsweek The Smiths and Chris Rock had a
decades-old personal and working
relationship prior to the slap in 1995
Rock guest starred on The Fresh Prince
of Bel Air where he and Will Smith
became friends a decade later Jada
Pinkett Smith and rock both voiced
characters in The Animated Madagascar
films over the years Rock has expressed
admiration for the Smiths and their
children however the Goodwill began to
turn sour in 2016 when Rock first used
the Oscar stage to mock the couple Rock
was asked to host the 2016 Oscars in the
wake of the 2015 Oscar so white
controversy when none of the 20 nominees
in the acting categories were people of
color when it happened again in 2016 The
Smiths and a number of prominent black
filmmakers boycotted the ceremony among
many other talented actors of color who
went without nominations many believed
Smith was snubbed for his performance in
concussion Rock poked fun at Will's
dashed Oscar hopes and at Jada's protest
in one of his monologues at the award
show speaking about will he said said
it's not fair that Will was this good
and didn't get nominated it's also not
fair that Will was paid 20 million
dollars for wild wild west and in a dig
at Jade is more subdued Celebrity Status
rock made the joke Jada boycotting the
Oscars is like me boycotting Rihanna's
panties I wasn't invited
the public nature of the slap provided a
window through which the public could
view Will and Jada Pinkett Smith's
infamously complicated marriage though
they've been married since 1997 Jada has
occasionally expressed some provocative
opinions about The Very concept of
marriage which may have led to the
public perception that she was less than
content eventually gossip began to
spread that Jada had engaged in an
affair with singer Mark Anthony and that
the Smiths had an open relationship in
fact the couple even separated for a
time though they remained legally
married I was devastated even worse than
a divorce we we broke up within our
marriage things reached a fever pitch in
2020 when singer August Alcina asserted
that will had given him his Blessing to
date his wife though Jada's Camp again
denied the story she and will aired
their marital problems with more
specificity during an episode of her
talk show red table talk Jada admitted
that she had been in a relationship with
Alcina while she and Smith were in the
midst of their trial Separation Will
went into more detail about their ups
and downs in his 2021 Memoir The Smiths
remained together but their reactions to
Chris Rock's joke at the 94th Oscars
were scrutinized through the lens of the
Intrigue surrounding their love life
only seconds after the slap the
entertainment industry and the public at
large sorted into two sides one that
defended Chris Rock's joke and one that
defended Will Smith's anger it is uh it
is Monday
unless you're Chris Rock because I'm
pretty sure he got slapped into next
week in the room Smith was comforted by
the likes of Bradley Cooper Denzel
Washington and Tyler Perry elsewhere in
the audience attendees including Serena
Williams Seth stunt but while some
celebrities like lakeith Stanfield Queen
Latifah and Minnie Driver expressed
empathy for all parties involved many
threw their support behind either Smith
or Rock Judd Apatow Amy Schumer Mark
Hamill Stephen Colbert Kathy Griffin Zoe
Kravitz Mia Farrow O.J Simpson and many
more were appalled that Smith resorted
to violence or expressed concern about
the precedent that Smith may have set
for audience members attacking comedians
others like Tiffany haddish Nicki Minaj
Sophia Bush and Will's son Jaden Smith
either sympathized for will or
criticized Rock for his insensitive
one-liner the general public's opinion
seems to be split down the middle in the
aftermath countless think pieces would
be written about how the slap related to
Rey's toxic masculinity mental health
and Myriad other topics the incident was
far too thorny for anyone to fully
figure out but that didn't stop
thousands from weighing in
in the interest of the many other
honorees in attendance producers for the
Oscars decided to keep the broadcast
going after the slap after the fact the
organization tweeted a short prepared
statement disavowing Smith's actions and
celebrating the other nominees upon
winning his best actor Oscar Will Smith
seemed to understand immediately that
he'd forever tarnished what was supposed
to be his big night still somewhat
unexpectedly Smith received a standing
ovation from most of those in attendance
which tin sit well with some in the room
and others watching from home the
atmosphere of the event was made more
tense by Will's speech he spoke for well
over the allotted time for Oscar
recipients and used his soapbox to make
some questionable comparisons between
his assault on Chris Rock and Richard
Williams parenting style positioning his
actions as born out of love for his
family however for many listening this
analogy only brought to mind language
used by many abusers to repackage their
emotional and physical abuse as love
after the awards show concluded Smith
preemptively resigned from The Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences and
weeks later the organization announced
that he would be banned from the Oscar
ceremony and any other related events
for 10 years his punishment did not
however exclude him from being nominated
for future Awards Smith publicly
accepted these decisions in a statement
for his part Will Smith has tried to
make amends and move on he put out a
YouTube video in July 2022 outlining his
progress saying that he apologized to
rock and his family Jada and their own
family as well as his fellow 2022
nominees it really breaks my heart to
have stolen and and tarnished tarnished
your moment he also said that he reached
out to rock directly and even though the
comedian did not press charges he was
not yet ready to talk during his press
tour for emancipation Smith spoke to
former The Daily Show host Trevor Noah
about the slap and acknowledged he
created a mess for himself Smith does
have upcoming projects in the works
primarily as a producer and a potential
Bad Boys 4 is still up in the air though
his star may eventually Rise Again Will
Smith's name and reputation will forever
be associated with the unfortunate
episode that marked one of the best and
worst days of his life
foreign